and The Washington Post reports on the
resignation of Fox News executive bill
shine amid the channels harassment and
discrimination scandal shine became
co-president less than a year ago in a
memo to employees the head of the
channels parent company Rupert Murdoch
said quote I know bill was respected and
liked by everybody at Fox News we will
all miss him
Jericka Duncan is outside Fox News
headquarters in New York Jericka good
morning good morning for years bill
shine was the right-hand man of Roger
Ailes the former Fox chairman who was
forced out in July amid sexual
harassment allegations now some have
said that shine enabled that sort of
misconduct at Fox it's an accusation
that shine has denied he got a start
here at Fox as a producer for Sean
Hannity well now that shine is out
Hannity is in the spotlight after bill
shine stepped down all eyes turned to
Sean Hannity I want to welcome all of
our friends from the all left propaganda
media I kind of suspect me be tuning in
tonight last week in response to reports
Sean was being pushed out hannity
tweeted that's the total end of the FNC
as we know it on monday the network
denied reports its biggest remaining
star was following shine out the door
all the lies you've heard about me are
not true it's a really demoralized
newsroom right now variety managing
editor joe bell Bruno says shines
proximity to Fox's sexual harassment
scandal caused his downfall what the
allegations are in this case is that he
helped Roger Ailes cover it up he helped
protect some of their top folks like
Bill O'Reilly I'm Horan racist behavior
at Fox News
Douglas wigged or an attorney who filed
a race discrimination suit against shine
and other executives said in a statement
while long overdue we are pleased that
21st Century Fox has taken a step in the
right direction
hello I'm Diana Fowley on monday
reporter Diana Falzone hit Fox with
another lawsuit alleging discrimination
based on gender and disability in
January she wrote about her infertility
due to endometriosis
Falzone suit claims that
revelation detracted from her sex appeal
and made her less desirable in the eyes
of Fox executives who ordered her off
the air to Fox News veterans were tapped
to replace shine Jay Wallace and Suzanne
Scott but Scott like shine has been
implicated in some of the lawsuits
against the network the talk now is that
will there be even more change will she
be in there for the long haul and can
she really turn around the culture
CBS this morning reached out to Fox for
a comment regarding the Diana falzone's
lawsuit we have not received a common
back the network continues to vehemently
deny any racial discrimination claims as
for Bill shine Fox says he will be here
for another few weeks to help with the
transition Gail thank you very much
Eureka